this video was made possible by news
voice a democratized news app created to
fight back against the filter bubbles
caused by corporate media download for
free from news voice calm slash Pakman
or click the link under this video
anytime we talk about the deficit and
the national debt at this point I find
it irresponsible not to remind you that
this is a political football that and
deficit aren't something that
Republicans actually care about they
care about it when it's a Democrat in
the White House Democrats also play the
game although more in a sort of reactive
way when the truth is that debt and
deficit matter depending on why we're
going into debt and growing the deficit
and I've talked about that before and
we're gonna get into that again that
being said we were told that Donald
Trump was going to cut the deficit he
was going to get us out of this deficit
problem
he and his ilk have identified that this
is a major problem and they were gonna
fix it but we now have new data and the
United States budget deficit has grown
to its largest in six years dating all
the way back to the Obama presidency the
US budget deficit is now larger than it
was at any point during President
Obama's second term the government is
actually spending more in 2018 and the
deficit is increased by 17% to 779
billion in the current fiscal year and
according to current estimates the
budget deficit will surpassed a trillion
will surpass 8 trillion by 2020 and this
is there's sort of two sides to this
right there's revenue and expenditures
Trump's tax cuts revenue to the
government have caused a decrease in the
growth of government revenues from zero
point from 1.5 percent last year two
point zero four percent this year
Trump's also spending more on the
military not exactly where we need to be
spending more at this point so the
important story here for me and I've
been making this effort whenever we talk
about debt and deficit probably for the
last what would you say year to year and
a half that we've been taking this sort
of approach the important story is not
the deficit itself
it's why we have a growing deficit and
it's Republican and Trump hypocrisy on
the issue the latter the hypocrisy you
know about by now they define social
responsibility is balancing the budget
and then they come in and they unbalance
the budget more than anybody george w
bush did it Donald Trump is doing it now
the hypocrisy
you're familiar with once we realize
that the deficit in and of itself isn't
the problem that in a growing economy
you can have a deficit that grows in
terms of raw dollars but that doesn't
necessarily mean that it's growing in
terms of relative size compared to the
economy what really ultimately matters
is why the deficit grows in our case
right now the deficit is climbing
because business has got a tax cut and
Trump is spending more on the military
to really simplify right and the tariffs
aren't going to help since they're going
to affect tax revenue as well in general
when business income goes down tax
revenue to the government from that
income also goes down just perfectly
logical if the deficit had climbed
because imagine that we gave a tax
credit to the poor and we combine that
with spending more on education that
would be a much better deficit for the
economy and it would be a different
story altogether if the deficit had gone
up because we decided we're gonna
subsidize alternative energy and we are
going to make cuts to the number of
bases that we have around the world that
would be a really good way for the
deficit to expand we need to take that
view on debt and deficit it's not this
Republican Democrat thing of deficit
good deficit bad balanced checkbook good
unbalanced bad as long as it's the other
parties guy or gal maybe at some point
what we have to understand is that not
every deficit dollar is created equal
and this is one of those things where
neither party benefits from pointing
this out they it's sort of like a race
to the bottom because the other party
will play the deficit bad surplus good
game everybody has to play it and you
never really end up getting honest
discussion about it from our elected
officials yeah it's typically the
Republicans who went out on this issue
even though you know Bush raised the
deficit Clinton lower the deficit Obama
lowered the deficit
Trump raise the deficit yeah and
remember Trump promised that even though
these numbers didn't seem to add up he
said that there would be so much
economic growth under his president it
would make up for all of it it would
make up for all of it and actually we
could cut we could pay down the national
debt by the end of his second term yeah
so far we're growing it we're continuing
to grow it and more importantly at an
even faster rate but again the we we've
got to talk about that but we also have
to talk about the fact that this is a
losing issue in general because it's
being discussed in terms it's a losing
issue for the left because it's
discussed in terms that the right has
established and that is really important
to understand here